Speaker 1: I'm really glad
to see that more and more
of Fox News hosts are being confronted with
the hypocrisy of their going completely crazy
about the vaccine mandates that are being put in
place by various companies. While not mentioning
that Fox News itself actually has a stricter
mandate than that which most companies have.
And that which was proposed by Joe Biden for
companies of 100 or more employees. So yesterday
we had this clip from Fox and Friends.
Were they completely unbelievably said
we don't have a mandate, we have a protocol. We
looked at the definition of the word mandate. We
looked at the definition of the word protocol and
we determined they have both. It's the same thing.
It's a distinction without a difference at the
difference, without a distinction. Whatever word
or phrase you want to apply to it, it was B.S.
and it was not believable. Today we're going to go
and look at another one of these confrontations,
and this one is with Tucker Carlson. Now, this one
is really interesting because Tucker Carlson has
been one of the most sort of prominent purveyors
of the attacks on vaccine requirements,
even saying the vaccines don't even really
seem to work. And the vaccines might have killed
thousands of people in all these different things.
Media Matters has a great article on this fox
personalities trying to distance themselves
from Fox's vaccine mandate, even though Fox
News's requirements for unvaccinated workers
are stricter than those recommended by
the Biden administration. Network hosts
continue to attack vaccination policies and
compliance protocols. FOX personalities and
guests have insisted the mandates and testing
requirements are akin to Jim Crow laws, apartheid,
eugenics, forced sterilization and discrimination
against those affected by HIV aids.
The Biden administration policies
Fox has spent months demonizing
require companies with 100 or more employees to
ensure that staff is vaccinated or test weekly.
Fox Corporation's policy is get vaccinated or test
daily and enter your status into an online portal.
More than 90 percent of Fox employees report being
vaccinated. OK, so now this is great. This is a
clip from Save the Nation, Vincent Jason, and they
bring this to Tucker Carlson on October 13th. He
does this maniacal laugh. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: OK, so I have a question here about
Fox News. Yeah, you said Fox News has no vaccine
mandate. But according to Newsweek, the company
requires unvaccinated employees to submit to daily
COVID testing, which is stricter than Biden's
mandate, which calls for weekly testing. Right?
Businesses that employ more than 100 people.
Is Fox News denying the civil liberties of its
employees by being stricter than President Biden?
Fair? I don't know. I mean, you should
probably ask Newsweek. It sounds like
they've got a pretty precise handle on WhatsApp.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so that's not a serious answer.
All right. But let's continue.
Speaker 2: Hey, if it's wrong,
let me know if I'm wrong. Yeah, I it's it's it's
completely wrong. As I noted the other night,
I'm not, you know? So what is the policy?
I'm not supposed to speak for the company
Speaker 1: on this, but as an employer, so
that's that's just that's just, you know,
B.S. as an employee. He could speak to his
understanding of the policy he's subjected
to. I mean, he's subjected to the policy. So
you don't have to speak for the company because
Speaker 2: I don't run the company and I'm not,
you know, I'm just an employee of the company.
Speaker 1: My personal tell us as an employee
the policy you've been subjected to and that
you've agreed to reference is that
Speaker 2: Fox News would, you know,
make a statement about what its policies are.
But I think like a lot of companies, you know,
they're hesitant to do that because like, why
would you even want to get involved in that
conversation? Here's the bottom line. You know,
there are a lot of infectious diseases out there,
a lot and a lot with much higher mortality rates
than COVID 19. True. And you know, there's HIV,
of course there's tuberculosis. Of course,
there are a bunch of different varieties for
hepatitis which have killed many hundreds
of thousands of Americans over the years,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. And
employers are not empowered. In fact, they're
not allowed to ask employees what their status
is or HIV positive. Really? Can you be tested?
Speaker 1: We test people, so notice that
this is this is now a Gish gallop, OK?
There's no vaccine for HIV. First and foremost,
OK. Secondly, we're talking about asking employees
vaccination status, not disease status. Number
three, HIV is far less contagious than COVID,
it's a sexually transmitted disease,
it's a. I hope people understand the
way in which this is a verbal inkblot.
There's no real substantive answer here
Speaker 2: based on their sexual, but HIV is
in a communicable diseases the same way. Like
you can't you can't sneeze on somebody and
give them HIV, right as he is killed has killed
tens of millions. Oh, yeah, no.
Speaker 1: Now that's a different now.
Now notice how the goalposts are different. The
death toll of HIV over 40 years now is different
than how contagious it is. It also means that you
can't just walk by someone and they sneeze and you
have HIV. This is really I don't think Tucker is
this stupid. So I think this is just bad faith.
Speaker 2: I don't. I don't doubt that. But you
can't carry on a global disease in the same way
you have to have sex or shared blood, correct?
Well, sure. At this point, do you transmit it?
So it is by definition, communicable.
Speaker 1: And he said it's not
communicable in the same way. And he's right
Speaker 2: now, and it's communicable in the same
way. But that's my point. Just to be clear, I am
totally opposed to asking anybody his HIV status.
Speaker 1: So now look at what he's doing. This
is a it's really a clinic in disinformation.
Now, Tucker is saying he's against the thing
he mentioned, which is not even analogous to
COVID vaccination status. He now says COVID.
So he's he said COVID vaccination status
is analogous to asking HIV status. And he's
against he's not saying ask people HIV that
we're not even talking about the same thing
anymore. The first question was. Doesn't
your company have a stricter policy than the one
Biden suggests, which Tucker got out of by saying,
Listen, I don't I don't speak for Fox News, but
Speaker 2: I'm totally opposed to asking
his prostate cancer status or what?
Speaker 1: Prostate cancer? Now, now we're in.
Now we're in Lulu. You know, Lou Nylund when we
now with prostate cancer, HIV is communicable
through flu, if through through sexual contact,
sexual fluids, blood now with prostate cancer,
what are we even talking about? This
has nothing to do with medical privacy.
Speaker 2: His latest blood
sugar levels are we had HEPA
laws for a reason, so I'm hired to do a job.
Speaker 1: And now now raising HEPA HEPA has
absolutely nothing to do with this whatsoever, so
look at the way in which Tucker is unable to give
any serious answer. Fox's policy is stricter
than the one Biden proposes. Tucker first says,
I don't speak for Fox News. No, but you're an
employee. You could tell us what they told you.
You can tell us what decision you made about
going with it in order to continue working
there. That's number one. He doesn't answer.
Then he goes into HIV, then he goes into HIV
status versus vaccination status, then prostate
cancer, then HIPA. This is not about HIPA. HIPA
has to do with the transmission of medical records
and privacy by medical providers. We're off the
deep end, folks, so look at how quickly he
fell apart under just basic questioning.